bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pendant la suspension
des travaux parlementaires je vous
propose de voir ou de revoir les enfants
de la dernière session du sénat et place
ce matin à l'audition de vincent bolloré
le président du conseil de surveillance
de vivendi qui a fait face aux sénateurs
de la commission de la culture au mois
de juin
l'occasion pour lui de s'exprimer sur
les résultats des chaînes du groupe
canal+ qui sont en berne
mais l'ue a estimé que canal+ était au
contraire désormais redresser et vous
allez le voir à la surtout été interrogé
à plusieurs reprises sur la question de
la liberté éditoriale sur les chaînes du
groupe
après la déprogrammation d'un
documentaire d'investigation sur le
crédit mutuel est pour lui la réponse
est claire circulez il n'y a rien à voir
tout cela ce ne sont que des rumeurs
lancées par les enfants gâtés de canal+
mécontent je le cite d'être mise à la
diète
pas sûr que cela est convaincu les
sénateurs voyez tout de suite leurs
échanges avec vincent bolloré
je vais essayer dans toutes ces
questions de mettre un peu de réponses
bien sûr et et peut-être dans l'ordre
d'abord me présenter à vous puisque
c'est la première fois que j'ai
l'honneur d'être auditionnés au sénat
j'ai passé dix ans dans la banque je
viens d'une vieille famille bretonne et
j'ai repris à 35 ans un groupe qui était
plutôt petit et qui est aujourd'hui l'un
des premiers groupes mondiaux puisque
avec plus de 10 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires plus de 50000 personnes
travaillant avec nous nous faisons
partie des 200 premiers groupes dans le
monde
nous sommes toujours basée à ergué
gabéric qui est donc à côté de quimper
et nous avons trois métiers le premier
c'est la logistique et le transport que
nous avons construit en une trentaine
d'années nous sommes le quatrième
opérateur mondial et le premier privé
français bien sûr de loin nous sommes
également dans le stockage de
l'électricité
l'un des premiers groupes mondiaux ceci
permet à la fois de faire des véhicules
qui peuvent rouler à l'électricité
voitures bus tramway mais aussi bien sur
le stockage des énergies nouvelles
solaire et éolienne qui sont
intermittentes et grâce au stockage
devienne permanente
mais bien sûr ce qui intéresse cette
commission c'est notre troisième métier
c'est-à-dire les médias les contenus que
nous avons développé depuis une
quinzaine d'années nous avons
aujourd'hui le deuxième journal français
en audience qui est direct matin qui est
élu qui est diffusé à près d'un million
d'exemplaires élu par à peu près deux
millions et demi de personnes
nous avons la première ou la bêtise on
la cinquième agence mondiale de
publicité qui est havas et il y a un peu
plus de trois ans et demi nous avons
accepté l'offre de vivendi qui était
d'apporter nos chaînes l'a8 et la 17
contre deux et demi pour cent du capital
de vivendi vivendi était en fête le
concentré de deux groupes
un premier groupe qui était la générale
des eaux groupe plus que centenaire et
sa fusion avec havas au début des années
2000 qui a donné une reconversion
complète sous la présidence de jean
marie messier qui a revendu l'ensemble
de ses activités non médias et s'est
beaucoup développé puis il ya une
douzaine d'années
l'endettement de vie 20 10 a entraîné le
départ de jean-marie messier et
l'arrivée d'une équipe qui a géré l
endettement en le transformant en
société financière lorsque nous sommes
rentrés dans viven dit le groupe bolloré
nous avions une idée assez simple qui
était au fond qu'à côté de la culture
américaine qui est assez maintenant
marquer invasive diraient certains en
tout cas marqué je dirais batman
superman enfin bref de l'action de la
force à côté de la culture asiatique qui
est sans doute un peu hermétique pour
certains la culture européenne avait
sans doute une place à prendre dans les
médias dans le monde
et le développement de la digitalisation
permet maintenant un émetteur qu'il se
trouve n'importe où dans le monde grâce
au digital d'émettre des programmes
partout de la même façon qu'on se plaint
en disant mais les groupes apple et les
gaffes à vont venir sur la france eh
bien les français peuvent bien sûr aller
à l'étranger puisqu'il suffit de
rajouter un petit instrument derrière
votre télévision et vous avez la
télévision qui vient du monde entier
sans n'avoir plus besoin comme avant de
passer par des réseaux classiques
c'est ce pari que nous avons fait et sur
un constat qui est qu'il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui en france ou qu'il n'y avait
pas il ya deux ans tout cas en france
un groupe qui avait envie de devenir le
champion français de cette culture dans
le monde
quand vous regardez aujourd'hui le
panorama des acteurs français
vous aviez le groupe lagardère qui pour
des raisons financières et limité dans
ses expansion internationale le groupe
tf1 qui a toujours choisi de rester en
france et qui a revendu ses activités
internationales comme eurosport les
chaînes publiques qui sont limités par
leur financement et puis c'est tout
puisque le groupe de l'a6 est contrôlé
par l'allemand bertelsmann donc c'est ce
constat à la fois la possibilité de
développer la culture française à
travers le monde
ils ont européenne ou latine et le fait
qu'il n'y avait pas de champions
français
nous sommes donc monté à 5% du capital
en rajoutant à peu près 500 millions
d'euros et j'ai été nommé au conseil et
le président précédent ainsi que
l'ensemble du conseil de surveillance
nous ont proposé de prendre la
présidence du conseil de surveillance de
vivendi avec comme objectif de faire de
viven du ce fameux groupe de contenu
qu'on peut distribuer à travers le monde
mon travail a consisté à nommer une
équipe parce que finalement dans la vie
vous posiez des questions tout à l'heure
sur mon rôle mon rôle c'est de fixer un
cap de nommer les équipes et de parler
avec elle pour vérifier qu'elles sont
bien toujours dans ce cas p qui leur
répondent quand ils ont des questions
nous avons donc nommé 1
une équipe autour de viven dit animé par
arnaud de puyfontaine qui nous fait
l'amitié l'honneur de venir aujourd'hui
qui est président du directoire il ya
quatre autres membres du directoire
trois français et un britannique mais
qui habite en france depuis une
vingtaine d'années et ce directoire en
lien avec le conseil de surveillance que
je préside a eu donc pour mission
transformer cette société financière en
un groupe industriel intégré la
différence entre les deux c'est que une
société financière ne s'intéressent pas
tellement à ce que fait industriellement
ses filiales mais s'intéresse aux
dividendes qui remonte et les laisse
indépendantes les unes des autres et les
gèrent de façon séparée
un peu comme le royaume de france à
l'époque où il y avait des régions
extrêmement forte avec des seigneurs à
la tête des régions et puis un groupe
industriel intégré fait l' inverse c'est
à dire que le groupe industriel intégré
prend les différents éléments qui font
partie du groupe et les fait travailler
ensemble et dans vive un deal exemple le
plus frappant était la musique qu'ils ne
travaillaient pas particulièrement avec
les chaînes de télévision c'étaient les
chaînes cryptées qui ne travaillait pas
particulièrement avec les chaînes
gratuites etc etc
donc le travail a consisté à nommer des
gens dans les différents endroits pour
qu'ils travaillent ensemble
en fait l'histoire de canal + qui est
souvent résumée
et synthétiser laisse à penser que je
suis arrivé dans canal+ et les problèmes
ont commencé
malheureusement les problèmes ont
commencé bien avant et il suffit de
regarder les différents documents qui
l'attestent je ne suis pas donc la cause
des problèmes de canal je suis la
conséquence des problèmes de canal est
peut-être la solution quand je dis je
c'est l'équipe de vivendi quand l'équipe
a été nommé à la tête de vivendi elle
s'est d'abord occupé d'universal music
parce que c'est le numéro un mondial de
la musique et il faut savoir que dans
les contenus aujourd'hui le premier
contenu dans le monde c'est la musique
et nous avons la chance d'avoir le
numéro un mondial qui représente 40% de
la musique dans le monde
les beatles les stones 6 août ou les
beach boys rihanna katy perry justin
bieber et plein d'autres bien sûr qu'ils
appartiennent à 100% à ce groupe
français le deuxième pas a été
évidemment de regarder canal
or canal malheureusement c'est un fait
on nous a présenté des résultats de
l'exercice 2015 de moins 260 et quelques
millions d'euros et un budget pour
l'exercice 2016 qui était à moins 400
millions pour les chaînes canal+ alors
là il ya une petite confusion dans
l'esprit des gens qui est dire oui mais
le groupe canal dans son ensemble gagne
de l'argent
certes le groupe canal gagne de l'argent
vous avez jean christophe thiery
apporter les les fiches avec les
derniers résultats des différentes
entités pour les sénatrices et les
sénateurs qui sont intéressés par
regarder les chiffres vous avez d'abord
une activité de cinéma qui est
complètement indépendant de ce que fait
canal qui est fait à peu près 600
millions de chiffre d'affaires et 60
millions de résultat 50 à 60 millions de
résultat vous avez ensuite une activité
internationale qui représente à peu près
deux milliards et demi de chiffre
d'affaires et qui fait à peu près 250
millions de résultat positif
vous avez ensuite canalsat qui fait à
peu près un milliard et demi de chiffre
d'affaires et qui dégage entre 200 et
250 millions de résultat positif
canalsat achètent des chaînes à
l'extérieur eurosport lagardère
ce n'est les autres et les revend à des
abonnés et puis vous avez les chaînes
canal+ celle dont vous avez parlé madame
la présidente celle sur pour lesquelles
nous sommes en effet avec une relation
avec l'état puisque nous avons des
fréquences qui nous ont été accordés et
celles ci perdent je répète les chiffres
268 millions 260 millions en 2015 et le
budget qui a été présentée de -400 en
2016 et mécaniquement le budget 2010 est
puisque les droits sportifs qui ont déjà
été signés en 2013 et en 2014 sont déjà
actés et sont payés obligatoirement
représenterait si rien n'a été fait plus
de 460 millions négatif de résultats
donc malheureusement ces chiffres sont
des chiffres
vivendi est un groupe coté des
commissaires aux comptes etc
enfin bref c'est assez risible de voir
des gens qui explique que le problème
n'est pas là alors on peut dire en effet
que la maison elle-même n'est pas tout à
fait en pertes mais en tout cas la
partie des pertes étaient en train
d'augmenter de façon tellement
importante que vivendi était obligé
d'intervenir et rapidement ses pertes
correspond non pas des pertes comptables
ce ne sont pas des opérations du passé
qui ont buzz qui aurait qui n'auraient
pas été provisionnées qui n'auraient pas
entraîné de besoins en cash
ce sont des pertes qui entraîne des
besoins en cash c'est à dire que vivendi
avait la nécessité
l'actionnaire de des chaînes de canal+
de remettre de l'argent au pot pour
couvrir ses pertes
étant entendu que le groupe canal dans
son ensemble a déjà un peu plus d'un
milliard de dettes et il n'a pas les
moyens avec les résultats qui fait de
s'endetter davantage donc c'était une
situation grave qui n'avait pas été
révélé par l'équipe précédente pour une
raison très louable qui est dire voilà
chaque fois qu'on dit canal+ va pas bien
c'est pas bon pour l'image donc c'est
pas bon pour les abonnés donc n'en
parlons pas et puis comme finalement
viven dit ne contrôlait pas en effet en
détail ce qui se passait bien la vie a
continué pendant plusieurs années comme
ça puisque les pertes de canal+ en
france ont commencé dans les années 2000
on
2012 c'est à dire au fond vous l'avez
dit vous-même madame la présidente sont
arrivés des concurrents puissants est
important donc nous sommes intervenus
chez canal à la fois pour mettre fin ses
pertes ce que doit faire toute entité
sociale responsable et aussi parce que
comme canal fait partie d'un ensemble où
les dits industriels nous ne pouvions
pas laisser un des pièces essentielles
de notre stratégie c'est à dire de la
distribution gratuite et payante et
éventuellement de la création de contenu
quitter le groupe ou s'arrêter à
l'intérieur du groupe
donc il était nécessaire de le faire
alors qu'avons nous fait il ya eu zéro
plan social rappelle que dans le groupe
canal et à 8000 personnes
nous avons changé 21 dirigeants je peux
vous le dire dans des conditions
financières extraordinairement agréable
pour les différentes personnes nous
avons changé ses dirigeants parce que
nous avons pensé qu' il était nécessaire
de mettre des dirigeants différents
qu'ils étaient capables d'aller
reprendre un oeil neuf qu'ils étaient
capables de plus travailler ensemble
bien évidemment nous avons gardé
certains dirigeants qui étaient là avant
et maxime saada directeur général qui
était je crois le numéro trois au numéro
4 est aujourd'hui le numéro 1 ou 2 en
tout cas le numéro un opérationnel du
groupe dans canal le directeur financier
qui est un normalien nommé grégoire
kaeslin est également là depuis je crois
une douzaine d'années
voilà donc c'est lui qui donne les
chiffres et donc les chiffres que je
donne sont les chiffres donnés par la
direction de canal
donc si vous voulez le programme est
assez simple où vous retrouvez devant
une société qui perd de l'argent
cette société il faut la redresser il
faut le faire le plus vite possible
parce que plus vous attendez
malheureusement plus les trous se
creusent et c'est ce que l'équipe qui a
été nommé chez canal est en train de
faire je comprends tout à fait l'émotion
quand tout d'un coup on croit que
l'avion dans lequel on circule est en
bonne forme et qui a plein d'essence
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya plus beaucoup de
kérosène et qu'il faut aller reprendre
de l'essence je comprends l'émoi
mais je peux malheureusement pas en tant
que responsable laisser passer la
situation est comme toujours puisque je
voulais dit ça fait 35 ans que je dirige
le combo blu ray le groupe bolloré je
voulais dit tout à l'heure est passée de
1 euro de valeur ou plutôt d'un franc à
plus d'une dizaine de milliards de
valeur sans faire d'augmentation de
capital c'est parce que nous avons
appliqué toujours les mêmes méthodes qui
est d'essayer de construire des sur des
axes stratégiques bien clair avec des
équipes compétentes et qui travaillent
ensemble et c'est ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui dans groupe vivendi par
arnaud de puyfontaine et directoire
et c'est ce qui est fait dans le groupe
canal par jean christophe thiery
président du directoire maxime saada et
les différentes personnes qui font
partie du directoire et du comex
je ne suis là que entre guillemets pour
prendre les coups ce qui est assez utile
pour les autres parce que je tire la
foudre sur moi et surtout pour assurer
une certaine continuité dans ce plan car
comme vous le savez sans doute le
problème dans les entreprises c'est
quand vous avez des actionnaires
financiers et qu'il ne vous empêche pas
d'aller au bout de vos projets
industriels c'est ce qui est arrivé à
jean marie messier personne ne peut dire
si ils avaient tord où il avait raison
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il a
été arrêté avant de pouvoir le démontrer
c'est ce qui me serait arrivé dans les
voitures électriques quand bertrand
delanoë a décidé d'équiper paris de
voitures électriques tout le monde
disait que c'était une folie
je n'aurais pas contrôlés grâce à mon
groupe familial cette division auraient
été jetés dehors bien évidemment avant
pareil chez havas que nous avons pris à
un moment tout le monde explique et le
très créatif allait partir et finalement
havas aujourd'hui est l'un des groupes
les plus en forme du monde dans le
domaine de la publicité et je crois
qu'il en est de même du groupe canal et
je pense que le travail qui est fait est
un travail qui va permettre bien
évidemment de redresser cette société ce
que je sais en tout cas c'est que si on
ne l'avait pas fait c'est sûr que vous
auriez un problème sur 8000 personnes et
sur des résultats importants
j'ajoute que wie 20 10 nous ne
compterons
on que 15% du capital de vivendi certes
25% des droits de vote mais que 15% du
capital de vivendi et que l'essentiel de
l'actionnariat de vivendi est entre les
mains de fonds pour l'essentiel anglo
saxons anglais américains ou autres et
que ces fonds ne sont pas intéressés par
ce qui se passe dans un pays par rapport
à un autre ils sont intéressés par les
résultats et un autre puits fontaines
pourra vous en dire un mot tout à
l'heure l'ensemble des grands
actionnaires qui sont d'ailleurs les
mêmes grands actionnaires que dans la
plupart des groupes français qui
s'appelle fidelity ligue and general etc
sont des groupes qui n'ont aucune envie
d'aller remettre 400 millions pas donc
j'indique je prétends que non seulement
il était nécessaire de faire cette diète
mais que celle ci l'a porté ses fruits
tout le monde sait d'ailleurs que le
groupe canal intuitivement était arrivé
au bout de son modèle mais peu importe
je dis je sers à nouveau à faire le
paratonnerre et c'est très bien
quand vous avez mon âge d'être utilisés
pour ça c'est bien ça permet aux équipes
de travailler en tranquillité sur les
chaînes gratuites de canal bien
évidemment nous avons un axe essentiel
qui est le cinéma vous savez que nous
finançons 500 millions par an de cinéma
dans groupe dont pratiquement 200
millions sur le cinéma français et nous
produisons à peu près 200 films par an
des grands des moyens et beaucoup de
petits et le groupe canal et moi même
puisque j'ai été de la même façon que je
suis auditionné aujourd'hui au sénat
représentant l'actionnaire de référence
j'ai été auditionnée par le monde du
cinéma à plusieurs reprises qui est venu
déjeuner avec nous et qui revient
d'ailleurs la semaine prochaine nous
avons affirmé urbi et orbi n'est variés
tueur que bien évidemment nous
souhaitions poursuivre le développement
du cinéma français et même l'accentuer
pourquoi et bien parce que ça rentre
dans la stratégie que j'ai indiquées
qui est que nous pensons que notre force
par rapport aux grands groupes
américains disney time warner et demain
ou aujourd'hui facebook google et autres
amazon ou netflix
nous pensons que c'est cette carte qui
est la carte essentielle les droits
sportifs sont des droits importants mais
moins important dans notre stratégie que
le développement du cinéma
ce cinéma d'ailleurs n'est pas limitée
au cinéma lui-même puisque nous ont des
séries et canal et investit énormément
dans des séries et nous commençons
maintenant avec une nouvelle filiale
appelée studio plus le développement de
mini série qui vont être notamment
diffusé sur les compagnies de téléphone
avec lesquels nous sommes alliés que ce
soit des alliances purement commerciale
ou technique ou que ce soit des
alliances capitalistiques
comme nous l'avons avec telefonica et
avec telecom italia
en gros vous l'avez compris la politique
de vie 20 10 c'est donc de développer
des contenus quelles sont ces contenus
le premier des contenus dans le monde je
l' ai dit tout à l'heure c'est la
musique
nous avons dans la musique le numéro 1
nous sommes très heureux de cocher cette
case
le deuxième contenu dans le monde en
termes d'utilisation aujourd'hui sur les
jeux vidéo malheureusement vivent 1 din
avec plus de jeux vidéo
vivendi est revenu dans les jeux vidéo
et nous avons annoncé vendredi avoir un
peu plus de 95% d'une affaire française
avec elle nous croyons beaucoup qui
s'appelle gameloft et qui développe
justement des jeux vidéo notamment sur
les mobiles
le troisième contenu c'est ce qu'on
appelle le stock c'est à dire les films
les séries les mini-séries tout ce qu'on
peut passer et repasser
donc là nous sommes assez puissant grâce
à studio canal en europe
nous ne sommes pas encore assez puissant
dans le monde et vie 20 10 a pour
objectif de faire des acquisitions ou
des développements et les développements
dans les mini série dont je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure qui est un
développement